oh it feels so good to be back so good
to be back if you're watching on YouTube
I am so tan don't be weirded out this is
my skin how are you guys I've missed you
all so much it is your boy the LEF koe
man and I'm super pumped to be here it's
been a wild two weeks let me just get
some show stuff out of the way for you
first up we are gonna have three
finalists for the new show name on
Wednesday to everybody that went and
filled out those forms appreciate it
some very funny names I enjoy stuff like
left coalition I like people that are
like all that's left Co I thought that
was really good but we're gonna go sort
of by a popular vote so we should have
three finalists for Wednesday's one for
you guys to vote on which will be great
it is still the classic intro song rod
Simba sent me a few possible new songs
and I'm gonna tell you that one of them
made me stand up and it made me kind of
dance and it's a little bit more my
speed and I know that this song is great
and rod and the regulator's are awesome
but this new one I am very excited for
you to get it so I I was gone the last
two weeks to anybody that went and
checked me out I did stop on Mina Kimes
his podcast so check that bad boy out we
talked about free agency franchise
tagging and it's funny we expected all
of these franchise tags and then what do
you know I forgot they're all waiting
until March 5th the deadline before they
slap it on a Grady Jared or slap on all
of the Marcus Lawrence so instead of
discussing whether or not they're gonna
be franchise tag we'll wait and see and
then we'll discuss it when it happens
because the new way of franchise tagging
is weeding until the very end I do want
to give a shout out to Charlotte and
waffle waffle master you guys are the
best Charlotte you're awesome keep being
the best I love you a lot
and I also want to say that just because
Sims is gone and just becomes French
vendrick is gone
I still want those
Brow's would rage master you did not get
out of this bet blake char win did not
catch 35 and i'm gonna need those
eyebrows I think the homies the 33%
needs those eyebrows they want those
eyebrows and we're not gonna sit here
and let you get away with it
because when I make a bet we are cashing
in if I lose or if I win speaking of
bets I'm betting my money you're gonna
like the interview we got in a little
bit is gonna be the main man Michael and
Bharti talking about what it was like to
go to the combine with Al Davis Bill
Walsh Bill Belichick what do you ask
when you only have 15 minutes in an
interview at the combine what does he
think about Kyle armory and Tonio Brown
levy on bail a lot of good stuff check
him out and then he's got an article
that came out today if you're listening
on Tuesday on the athletic about
handling the combine and all of that so
until then it is just me and the homies
but it has been a wild two weeks so I
kind of want to let you know what's been
happening and give you the inside scoop
for everyone that supported me as I was
doing play-by-play of the NBA Rising
Stars I'm gonna give you an applause
thank you guys for all the tweets it was
a lot of fun when I tell you that that
was my first time doing play-by-play
legitimately I'm not kidding weeks
leading up to the event I called I an
eagle and I said ayan I need your help
and I in goes and his voice is perfect
and he goes Adam listen I know you've
done this before at Syracuse and all
that so you're gonna be fine and I'm on
the other side of the phone and I'm
going but I'm not gonna tell him I
wasn't gonna tell anybody so but he gave
me advice about kind of owning it and
being conversational and making it fun
and I was like I got this I got this I
got this and it's with Frank Kaminsky
and Danny Green two guys they had never
done it before either and I was excited
I was nervous I was pumped and I'm
feeling all these emotions and I'm
waiting in the hotel and I'm waiting to
go over to the arena
and in the lobby for those of you that
are hip-hop fans is a Noreaga nori and
what a man he made so many great hip-hop
songs in the 90s and he is shellacked
like I'm talking about glean and his
eyes sparkle looking around and he looks
over at me and I got my suit on with my
top button buttoned I'm pulling the
Chris and he walks over and he goes you
know you to fly ass white [ __ ]
in this place and I said me he goes yeah
you want a hug
and I was like shore nori I'll take a
hug so Noriega hugged me and then he
sees my girlfriend the time and he goes
you know you were to fly a semaphore in
this place and I was like man so it was
so funny I'm nervous I'm excited I'm all
this stuff and it all dissipated because
Noor he wanted to give me a hug
went to the arena went out there you
know it's crazy man you're sitting at
courtside and there's Donovan Mitchell
and there's Ben Simmons and you know
there's Dirk Nowitzki in there and I'm
talking to dark in his ear and he's
responding and there's Kyrie and and
look I've been doing NFL now for a while
it was nice cuz none of them knew who I
was like I'm walking out there and
they're like what's up man like I think
I've seen you before and I'm like nah
nah dude I'm I'm more of an O'Dell guy
to be honest with you but it was a blast
it was super fun and it was sort of the
beginning of a lot of luck for me these
last two weeks to the point where you
don't even before that I'm at I'm at the
Sixers Lakers game I took my pops there
for his birthday and we're watching
LeBron and one of my rules and fandom
and I'm sure a lot of you guys at home
have rules
I do the wave some of you don't do the
wave some of you will never leave early
you will stay to the very end I will
occasionally leave but not if it's a big
game that's insane but one of my rules
is I never stand up for a free t-shirt
ever you know when that whole things
everybody get on your feet it's time for
a free t-shirt to us I can't do it
the t-shirts are never comfortable
they're always hard they're always a
double XL and I don't want them well at
that Sixers lakers game they're going on
right everybody other fans stand up for
those free t-shirts and i'm going
absolutely not and the announcer goes
what do you know lil Uzi vert is out
there throwing out t-shirts and I have
seen a little woozy vert in concert at
an Adidas concert and he was amazing and
I said well let me stand up and see this
and he's throwing it in the crowd the
way little Uzi does like completely not
trying to throw and then he goes up and
he just takes over one of those Gatling
guns like the the things where it's like
a tommy gun like buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh and he just starts spinning
everyone's laughing and if that t-shirt
didn't come right at my face I didn't
even move it was just like different it
I just caught it I'm going this is crazy
then after the Rising Stars game I take
my girl to the NBA all-star game on
Sunday and I'm sitting there and they're
going alright fans let's stand up for
those free All Star t-shirts a my and my
girls going oh I like when I go listen
and listen I don't think you understand
I don't stand up for this it's a bad
t-shirt as I'm explaining it a t-shirt
whizzes over my head hits the hands of
the person behind me falls into my lap
like not even it just into my lap that's
the kind of two weeks I've had since
I've seen you guys I lost all my boys
but the luck has been following me ever
since I mean so much so I'm going on
vacation with my girl we're going to
Anguilla I promise this is getting
somewhere and I had a layover in DC you
know and I actually got to be a part of
the Kapernick Reed settlement discussion
yeah I was in the meeting listen I've
been gone for two weeks I just want to
share with you where I've been and what
I've done I was in the settlement but
sign the NDA guys so I cannot tell you
how much capper
got from this deal it was a good amount
but I'm not allowed to because of the
NDA so I would have this greater I'm
telling him in my two-weeks have been
nuts I would have great information and
da's are tough and then I went to
Anguilla and it was amazing some of you
saw that I did propose to my girlfriend
who is now my fiancee and she did say
yes so big things are popping for the
lef koe man it's nerve-wracking for
those of the homies that haven't done it
it's a little scary you're mainly afraid
that you're gonna drop the ring or lose
the ring I think I patted that pocket
about seventeen thousand four hundred
and twenty six times it was very
intimidating but I think my favorite
part was that morning we're sitting at
breakfast and for everyone out there I
have kind of joked with my girlfriend
for a long time like I'm the guy that
like bends down on one knee and then
ties issue that's the kind of person I
yeah but you knew that you know I am but
we're at breakfast and you know I'm
joking and I'm like you know you know
what about like getting engaged in like
2021 and this is the day that I'm going
to do it and she she won't even make eye
contact with me and she looks and out in
the ocean and she goes at him you know
when we get back to New York we're gonna
have to have a long talk because I don't
think you're taking this as seriously as
you should I don't even know if I might
have to move and I'm sitting there and
I'm going oh but we got a massage and
then we went out on the beach and a suit
during sunset and I had photographers
hidden behind a bush and man I got
really nervous it was more nervous like
I didn't want to mess it up I wanted the
photographers to be the right place but
I got down on one knee she said yes it
was great and now everyone's asking me
when the wedding is and my answer to
them is I got a C when big Phil is
let me have it because if you don't
think me ask him on this podcast is a
contract
I am sending it to a lawyer and it is
going to be awesome and I want to have
the wedding at big Phil's house they
need it
all the way back I thought I had another
stop in Florida in an area Florida
well what Cydia what not Saturn on Mars
not I can't remember the name of it but
it it honestly the layover it came in
handy
you know because you want to get a grasp
of the situation
you know the travel the exhaustion it
can be tough when you want to do it all
yourself the planning and all that and
the last thing I needed it was in this
time of my emotional state was to get
rubbed the wrong way I didn't need that
would have been awful but you know the
story does have a happy ending because
we got back on time no mess nothing safe
and sound back in peace in New York yeah
I just can't remember what that area of
Florida was anyway whoa big offseason
you thought it was done it's never done
listen with the way this podcast is
gonna go whether it's people like Mike
Lombardi or we're gonna have more people
coming in studio hopefully soon and then
I'm gonna go out and being with all
these athletes I want to keep you guys
up to date with all the big news stories
that are going on not just the ones that
are tipping the scales and the front
page of the New York Times wherever but
also you know the completely random ones
like I don't know Arthur Blank buying a
hundred and eighty million dollar yacht
are you kidding of two hundred and forty
foot yacht that's what's so funny is
here we are we call Kaepernick greedy
and all these people greedy's and then
we wonder why they get upset when their
owner buys a yacht that's two and a half
football fields and is about is like
double their salary cap that's the whoa
big off seasons that I really like those
are the ones that I find to be so darn
fascinating but though big whoa big off
season thus far and I know the Ravens
just cut Crabtree but that
the season were in guys and you know
what I'm gonna give a shout out to my
man on Instagram pro football chase man
if this Instagram account if you need
news go to this guy I think I'm gonna
make him my new Adam Schefter I think
that's kind of what I'm gonna do is he's
on it all the time but yeah pro football
chase my man Isaac he's got he's like 23
years old he's got 86,000 followers but
he hold keep you up-to-date on all the
crazy stuff there but the biggest whoa
big offseason to me has been the
Steelers they've dominated and what's
really interesting is you've heard us
talk before about Seattle and Green Bay
last year we had all this hope that
because Green Bay and Seattle didn't
make the playoffs two years ago that it
would create finally some change and I
would argue that it has look at those
two franchises now Green Bay now has a
young up-and-coming offense of mind with
other offensive minds built around him
in the floor and friends that will have
a different offensive philosophy for
Aaron Rodgers which is what we always
wanted and that I think led to change
Seattle we had a number of issues about
them being able to protect Russell
Wilson I mean you can't talk to a
Seattle fan and mention Mike Solari
without them out getting really excited
their new offensive line coach that
offensive line was incredible last year
so they missed the playoffs and it led
to some positive change but what
happened was is you had to break it down
first to get to the change we're seeing
the breakdown right now in Pittsburgh
the difference is there was no wide
receiver or running back on Green Bay
that was gonna cause a lot of issues
there was no offensive line and Russell
sure as all wasn't gonna say anything
that we're gonna create issues in
Seattle
Le'Veon Bell Antonio Brown Ben
Roethlisberger these are mercurial
people with ego people that have
accomplished things people that will
tell you it sure as hell ain't my fault
so as the ship is burning as it has to
break to build it is gonna be messy in
the process so where are we right now
Le'Veon Bell is officially going to be a
free agent their GM has come out and he
has said that he's gonna let him go
Kevin Kolbert and he is a true free
agent but in the purest form of the NFL
not caring about the players what
happens Manish Mehta reporter in New
York comes out and says the Jets are
very concerned that Le'Veon Bell is
overweight
why do they do this the same reason you
try and flush out an animal underneath
your house I don't know how big it is I
want to see we haven't seen heard or
seen anything from levy on bail in a
long time and I'll be the first one to
say that when he was on that jet ski he
did not look in playing shape but what
happened as soon as they put out that
report sweaty Le'Veon Bell mid-workout
video on Instagram saying I'm gonna take
my 260 ass anywhere
my advice to levy on bail not just left
kopi are not just edited workouts and
all that stuff you gotta take those
pictures right in the morning cuz every
chubby guy out there knows you have
about a five to ten minute window when
you first wake up you've never looked
better
Le'Veon Bell needs that photo you got to
put it out there I might even do a
little cleanse I might even do a
three-day cleanse where you're drinking
all the juices in the waters and just
get yourself looking real thin post that
bad-boy
levy on Bella's doing the opposite of
Cuyler Murray Cuyler Murray is doing the
it's always in sunny philadelphia
carbo-loading building mass levy on bail
right now east shredding you're gonna
hear who Lombardi thinks he could be
going to but I look at levy on bail
I think everyone's gonna say the Jets
everyone's looking at Indianapolis
because they got a little bit of money
my favorites for him are two places
Houston and Miami we know why Miami boy
does he spend his time in Miami but you
know what Miami Houston Bost hat both
have a no income tax
none tech
in Florida this man cares about his
dollars also Miami other than me in a
home they can build around him he can be
the face they don't really have that
right now and then Houston the
possibility of him joining deshaun
Watson DeAndre Hopkins a healthy will
fuller everything they got going on
there I think that's pretty darn special
the only other one I would say is
Baltimore but I would say that Gus
Edwards kind of popped a little bit as
that was going the other guy is a
Antonio Brown and boy has this been
crazy
Kevin Kolbert comes out and says three
teams are interested which of course
spotlights that twenty-eight teams
haven't called 28 plus three is 31 and
then the Steelers are 32 but Peter King
and his article today had his top five
Carolina Washington Tampa the New York
Jets and Oakland Washington doesn't make
a lot of sense to me I just I can't see
them pulling the trigger on that they
don't know who their quarterback is who
knows what's gonna happen
Tampa is interesting because there are
new coaches Bruce Arians so the question
is is what was the relationship between
Bruce Arians and Antonio Brown I'm
talking my Ben I was talking about
Antonio Brown when it comes to the
Washington Tampa though I mean Bruce
Arians just came out and had some
comments about an Antonio Brown that
we're not glowing I don't think that
relationship is great I don't see a
trade like that happening New York Jets
maybe maybe I mean he would be amazing
with Sam darn old I just don't know if
I'm a Jets organization if I am trying
to take on Antonio Brown with a young
quarterback because the Antonio Brown we
have right now is a guy that's not
afraid to tell you how great he is
Oakland is interesting Oakland is
interesting especially when I hear Jon
Gruden come out earlier this week and
say you know trading is interesting Jon
Gruden has always been obsessed with
older made players look at last year's
free agency from Jordy Nelson to
everyone across the board to Doug Martin
to everyone that we knew had already
passed where they needed to be he trusts
them more than young people and you know
he has a love affair with Antonio Brown
but I will give Peter King the Don a lot
of
credit for the little nugget he had
about Carolina's GM and I want to share
with you so that you have the Nugget in
case you didn't see it new owner David
Tepper of the Carolina Panthers where is
he from Pittsburgh
he went to Pitt and Carnegie Mellon both
in Pittsburgh he had an ownership a 5%
stake in the Steelers before he came to
the Panthers and what do you know he
donated 55 million to CMU which has a
temper School of Business in his honor
Carnegie mail this man has invested in
Pittsburgh he knows what a Antonio Brown
made it meant to that city he's also
looking at his football team and going
I like DJ Moore he's a little
inconsistent you know I like I like
Curtis Samuel he's a little consistent
man if my if my incredible running back
just had a wide receiver that can work
the middle of field because I'm a little
bit worried about Cam Newton's ability
to throw the ball deep because of all
his arm issues man it would be really
nice to give a veteran wide receiver
that I know because remember this
everyone talks about how coaches have
ego and they believe that they could be
the one that gets through to somebody
you don't think a new owner feels the
same way this is a 5% owner of the
Steelers who watched Art Rooney have
incredible relationships with all of his
players I've talked to Jerome Bettis
Troma's told me stories about art about
Rudy bringing him into the room and
going hey Jerome what should we put in
the ring
tapper wants to have those relationships
and Antonio Brown is a star my only
thing and by the way the deadline for
Antonio Brown March 17th another great
point by Peter king Steelers Oh him a
two and a half million dollar bonus at
that time I did some reading on this
vacation and you know that my my thing
here with left coast sprinkles or out of
left go field is I like to take things
because I read books about history and
philosophy and a lot of times it applies
to the stories in the NFL and in this
case I read one that reminded me so much
of Antonio Brown
it was crazy I read in the story of
Coriolanus Coriolanus
if there's actually it's actually
there's a whole play written by
Shakespeare about it
he was a great military hero of ancient
Rome to the point where he had scars
that were so visible that people would
just applaud for him because of what he
did back in that time the wars he won
what he stopped what he did he was a
mythical figure and after he had led so
many Wars he eventually said you know
what I want to cash in all of my
accomplishments and I want to run for
the high rank of consul I want to use
all that I've accomplished and I believe
the people will love me so much that I
want to be a powerful politician and it
seemed like it was a shoo-in every major
politician supported him all the people
supported him the problem is no one had
heard him speak before Coriolanus was
this man that did all of his talking on
the battlefield
and what they didn't realized was he was
very cocky
no one knew this everyone assumed was
that the the warrior on the battlefield
is a silent assassin but when he took
the microphone he talked about how he
was gonna be the best leader that's ever
existed he was gonna bring so much
profit he was gonna do it better than
anybody else no one was gonna touch him
and that it was expected that he was
gonna win so what happened the public
started talking about I didn't know he
was like this he thinks he's just gonna
win he thinks he's just gonna be the guy
and you know what they did they voted
against him because they didn't like his
cockiness
what happened Coriolanus got upset at
the people and he continued to just talk
about them and yell at them there was a
shipment of grains that came in and my
man Coriolanus said the people don't
deserve it after how they talked about
me
he created a riot he went from someone
that was going to be the head of the
state to someone that they were riding
against to give him the death penalty
but because of his accomplished what do
they do they banished him he was asked
to leave and never come home again
and it's a reminder that a person who
cannot control his words shows that he
cannot control himself and is unworthy
of respect that is a warning in history
for what I'm seeing in Antonio Brown
Antonio Brown was the 6th round pick
that can never do no wrong that ran the
underneath routes and was the ultimate
toe tapper and played for the Pittsburgh
Steelers a franchise that was born in
the dust fields of an ironworker that
was made from the the nine to fivers and
came up through art mode excuse me the
Rooney family who I think got the money
to buy the team from a darn horse race
it was a romantic tale I mean I posted
on instagram the video of Antonio Brown
the combine I mean holy crap what a
modest young men but his talking lately
has really changed the whole perception
of it and I'd ask you guys this is I'm
not implying he has but I'm curious on
your thoughts has Antonio Brown done a
lot of damage to his name do you look at
Antonio Brown differently
I look at Antonio Brown and right now
I'm gonna say that I'm a little bit
confused because of the other man in
this triangle the triangle is the
Pittsburgh Steelers Antonio Brown and
ding dong Big Ben because while I look
at Antonio Brown and I go I can't
believe you're saying these things and
doing these things and going on Twitter
and talking and saying that I am in the
best and which is gonna rub people the
wrong way I'm also seeing this other ego
that you know I've called out a lot in
Big Ben Roethlisberger and I think it
got even more hairy when Kevin Kolbert
came out and made his comments about how
Big Ben has 52 kids under him quite
honestly and how Big Ben is the adult in
the room we know darn well the Big Ben
is on Theodore in the room Big Ben is
not practicing all the time Big Ben's
not wearing his helmet all the time we
laugh at the clip where he's knocking
down all the pads with the ball of
throwing it but we all know that that's
not what a leader
there's jokes that we all make about the
walking boot there's all the comments we
make and how we can throw people under
the bus I am having a hard time
evaluating if Antonio Brown is too much
of an ego if he does have an ego and
it's just matching Big Ben or if I'm
just sitting here looking at the fact
that big been marked avis Brian Antonio
Brown and Le'Veon Bell were all in the
same team and couldn't do anything but
I'm wondering as I look at Seattle and
what we learned from them and the
changes that happened and Green Bay what
we learn from them and the changes that
happen when you don't make the playoffs
and you lose change happens
Pittsburgh might lose everything they're
gonna lose levian they may lose a
Antonio but I think the thing that's
gonna change the most is Big Ben the
accountability it's gonna be on Eagle
watch I mean we're gonna be paying
attention to this guy all the time every
quote is that a leadership quote
everything he does is gonna be
interesting
what he needs to do is separate himself
from the front office because as I
witnessed as an Eagles fan with Donovan
McNabb if your quarterback is tied to
your front office you can lose the team
and he cannot have that happen I'll just
say this the Steelers are an absolute
mess right now and I'm very curious to
see how this figures out I'm not sure I
just hope for Antonio Brown who's been a
phenomenal player in this league that it
hasn't already gone too far Antonio
Brown he's done some left go PR in terms
of left go PR I don't know if you guys
have noticed it but holy crap is there a
ton right now Patrick mahomes Antonio
Brown I mean the funniest one is Kirk
Cousins if you haven't seen Kirk Cousins
IG it's like one camera shot of him
doing like sit-ups it's amazing but I
will give my first week of the offseason
left go PR award to Robbie Gould because
what Robbie Gould right now is doing is
man
I mean this is Odell levels of love co
PR never forget that the bear season
even though it was so successful will be
remembered by the double doink Cody Park
II and that if they had a better kicker
they probably believed they'd continue
on and who knows how far they go they
probably believe they can beat the
Saints they probably believe they could
beat the Rams cuz they did beat the Rams
but what Robbie Gould right now is doing
is the best I've ever seen
remember he went to that playoff game
against the Eagles and was in the crowd
and people were noticing him former
Chicago Bear has had two phenomenal
seasons with the San Francisco 49ers so
he put pressure on them during the
moment and then you know what he came
out and said this week I'm interested in
coming back to Chicago this is perfect
you get the fan base excited you get the
team excited they recently cut Cody
parky Robbie Gould I applaud you what
you've done is absolutely fantastic
we're gonna hear right now from Michael
and Barney the main man and then coming
up after the interview I'm gonna explain
to you what's wrong in the media
ecosystem right now and give you a
breakdown of what's coming up in the
calendar oh yeah you know we're talking
about all the stuff that's gonna happen
that I can already predict but right now
let's listen to Lombardi let's bring
them in the main man the mind that lets
the NFL know where it needs to go
Mike Lombardi at M Lombardi NFL make
sure you check out his book gridiron
genius I loved it I got through it at a
record speed it's al Davis it's Bill
Walsh it's Bill Belichick it's awesome
happy to have you on pal how you feeling
uh Thank You Adam I appreciate it
sounded kind of you to read the book I
certainly appreciate it
yeah and your writer at the athletic
you're doing all your great work at V
sin I'm just curious
this time of the year I imagine all the
NFL franchises they're getting packed up
they're going to Indy they're getting
ready to watch the underwear Olympics
what was the experience like with Al
Davis versus
bill walsh versus bill belichick how
would that compare well let's start off
with Bill Walsh because I started that
first I was Bill's book carrier this is
back in there early in the mid 80s
before Back to the Future and they
invented the book bags you know I'm sure
everybody had book bags but yeah you
know and Back to the Future Michael J
Fox made it popular so I didn't have a
book bag I was bills book bag I carried
his books everywhere and one of the
stories I tell in gridiron geniuses we
were in the combat we were at the
combine and this was just when it was
the old Hoosier dome there was nothing
attached to it and I was lugging his
books and he was walking through them
the crowd and he stopped short and
looked down on the field and in about 20
seconds passed by said to me who's that
down there throwing and I said I'll
coach that's Rich Gannon from the
University of Delaware he said make sure
Holmgren goes and works him out of
course I had to go tell holmgren that
and then the homeroom got all upset with
me because he thought I was making him
go see one of my Jersey guys and back in
Delaware so anyway so it was interesting
with coach Walsh I kind of just carried
his stuff got him from here to there
didn't really know what he was thinking
one year we had it in Phoenix that was
outdoors it was the year Jerry Rice ran
a 40 on the grass out there freezing
cold in Arizona we just won the
Superbowl and then we moved to New
Orleans the next year and then the year
after it's settled on Indianapolis and
everybody thought it would last maybe a
year because the winters would be too
harsh and here it is going on almost 25
years there so that was fun
Bellingham was just all work you know we
we would it wasn't set up the way it is
now we would bring a video a betacam
projector to the combine set it up in
one of the rooms start watching tape
work on tape during the drought during
the time try to find players to bring
them in to interview them before they
had the system in place which is now
utilized where you only get 15 minutes
to interview players and so it was
mostly all work trying to negotiate
contracts the cap came in and then
things started to change because the the
the cap was so important and meeting the
agents became as important as the 40
times on the field because you knew we
were going to watch those when you were
doing the film study later
day and then without it was you know I'm
all for tea time well you know they
should really I wrote this for the
athletic it will come out tomorrow I
mean they should really name the combine
the Al Davis Invitational he loved it he
loved it more than anything and he had
his seat right there and at the 40-yard
starting line he didn't care about
player interviews he he all he cared
about was watching the players work out
watching them run got their forty times
he always had a hot dog with mustard on
a break at lunch early today yellow
brown what kind of mustard just yellow
right down just down the middle just
mustard and then dot coke and then he
would have that and then he would work
and he'd have a tape machine in his room
he would go back and watch tape and he
would work out and right around 9:30 or
8:30 9:30 at night he'd have dinner
every night at the Shoeless steak house
at the Westin you know and the meal
would consist of English cut prime rib
you know french fries were big potato
whatever he wanted and of course he had
German chocolate cake for dessert so it
was pretty easy with Al you just worked
late at night because he was always
working he was always doing stuff at
night because he was a night house so
yeah and then he you'd get to get up in
the morning and start your daily routine
but it was always good he loved it what
do you think of what the combine has
become having been to so many of them
well I think it's really it's it's about
the it's really about character
assessment I it's a four prong that's
you know it's funny I wrote about this
for the athletic tomorrow it'll come out
and I talked about how it's really a
four prong event in the sense that you
know part one part is is Monte Gras
which is a lot of people they're at a
party and have a good time at the bars
another part is like World Series of
Poker tournament because there's agents
there trying to negotiate contracts and
trying to figure out you know what's
going on and you got to play poker
basically who's bluffing who's not and
then there's the triage center which is
a bunch of the players are on tables
getting their bodies pulled and tugs or
directions to see how they are medically
orthopedically and then there's the on
the field workouts and then
of course there's the guys looking for
job so it's a job fair it's a Vienna
character assessment conference it's a
little bit of everything so you
mentioned the 15 minute interview would
you ask the same questions to every
person was there one type of question
you definitely wanted to ask how do you
maximize that time to evaluate character
in a quarter of an hour well I think you
have to do your homework before you go
in with the interview correct so you
know I'm not gonna ask this I'm not
gonna ask somebody the same questions
because not all the players are the same
so my if there's a player that I have to
deal with on a character assessment
issue you know I'm I'll start the
interview off this way I'll say look
every question I'm gonna ask you I
already know the answer to so I'm just
gonna see if you're gonna lie to me so
just come clean let's talk about it we
all make mistakes in life we all have
our problems so it wasn't actually
questions you are curious about you're
looking to confirm to see if they can
look you in the eye and be honest
exactly that's the fashion I wanted to
see what what the person was you know
and then I want to be able to assess how
he dealt with it you know how he handled
the situation you know look I made this
mistake I'll never do it again you know
I mean remember when we started the
combine in 82 84 smoking marijuana was
you know oh my god it was a penalty by
death almost right
and today it's legal in seven states so
you gotta adapt your thinking and your
processing going along and and how you
judge player I think the best way for me
to handle the interviews I watch the
wire repeatedly realize yeah of course I
mean here I'm a fat white kid growing up
in New Jersey you know I don't know I'm
interviewing african-americans from the
inner city I don't have any idea the
plight did they walk up and walked in
their shoes how can I judge anything
that they've done hmm you know and the
wire was enlightening to me it was like
holy hell this is this is a world I
don't know I need to learn more about
this so you start reading books about
the things that are going on in
inner-city America to help you
understand that the kid you're trying to
evaluate it's interesting because when I
read that book what was the one we were
talking about the guy that did Moneyball
and all that and he had the one about
biases and all that Michael Oher yes
Michael Louis he had that book recently
you know the Houston Rockets don't even
look at the answers they don't factor it
in because you can get emotionally
unstable or it can kind of move you off
your bearings by feeling emotional about
somebody's response
did you ever interview somebody and they
blew you away and it did impact your
evaluation you know uh yeah I think so
there's no doubt I mean look I can go
back and I wrote about it in the book
Ray Lewis blew me away
I mean we interviewed Bill when I
interviewed Ray Lewis and Lawrence
Phillips at the same time and I wrote
about it in the book Ray Lewis knew
everything that was going on the tapes
he came to life he was so engaged and
excited about it you know where's
Lawrence Phillips was just dull he just
didn't care I didn't know I don't I
don't even know who were playing here he
had no idea you know now does that mean
that I could tell you Lawrence Philip
was going to have the unfortunate life
that he had and foreign died in prison
no I didn't know that however that being
said you know you could tell that it
wasn't as important to him as it was to
Ray Lewis you could feel it but you know
that that was a little that was a long
ago recently you know we interview Trey
flowers when I was at the Patriots and
you could just feel that he knew what he
was doing he was humble he was confident
grew up in northern Alabama had one
scholarship offer too and then late
Arkansas came in and he took that deal
and so you know it was just it was one
of those where you kind of got a sense
of who this kid was in just 15 minutes
and you can do it there are a lot of
stories and sources that are gonna come
out this week because of all the agents
and the players how much should we
actually believe do you think well I
think you should believe very little of
it I mean you know I think you have to
do your homework I mean look it's like
every time you pick up the morning paper
do you believe everything you read the
paper you better not its source seasoned
man I'm just seeing anonymous Scout says
Kyler Murray should be second round pick
and I can't believe it's even being
printed well I mean look look it's you
know guys want to get you know guys want
to be quote quoted I mean look as Art
Modell used to tell me all the time you
know the guy maybe the janitor is the
source here are sources in the
organization senators you just never
know so he says I think it is you know
I don't I don't know why people are so
willing to share their opinions about
players I mean I think the whole mock
drafting is completely out of touch I I
treated this today and I'm not gonna bag
on anybody but I mean three years ago
the year Patrick mahomes Mitchell true
Biscay deshaun Watson all those guys
came out there were there were a
prominent NFL examine an NFL or
prominent TV mock drafter had his second
mock draft mock draft 2.0 and mahomes
wasn't even in it wow that's really all
you need to know right well but I don't
I don't mean that as an indictment
towards the guy it's it's just that
there's not enough information I've been
collected at that point to really make
accurate assessments the real issue so
Mike I feel like everything I always
hear about the combine is you should
have all of your work done and this
shouldn't impact you that much what was
is that true do you believe that no of
course not because first of all most of
these guys we don't even have the
accurate height weights and speed we
need so we need to know what their
height weight and speed are there's no
that you have to know that right we
don't know the medical on any of these
players yeah assess the character on any
of these players right we don't know any
of that so yeah now do you base it just
on what he did the short shuttle on of
course not I mean this is like you're
building a cake you know these are these
are ingredients that go into the cake
they're not the one thing and so I think
you've got to be very careful and
prudent about how you handle the
information I believe that already this
year's draft seems to be defined by
Cuyler Murray and where he goes it's an
interesting prospect a two-sport
professional athlete in terms of the
ability to be drafted a Heisman Trophy
winner the the measurables that are
gonna come in for Kyler what is what is
the line the Michael and Barty line
where if it's below a height or a weight
it would be hard for you to take him
what are those lives I don't really have
one I think I think it's about seeing
them looking at his body so you know I
mean knowing that look it regardless
whether he's 509 6 or 510 - right you
know he's gonna have trouble seeing he's
gonna
trouble singing and if you're willing to
accept this if you're willing to say
look we can work around it then the next
question isn't okay let's just do it the
next question is tell me how we're going
to work around it
tell me how are we never going to be in
under center how are we going to handle
it because look you can talk to any
player that played against Oklahoma you
know including the guys that were at
Alabama they knew he couldn't see over
them they knew it now he made some
incredible plays and when the place
broke down he became a unbelievable
player but if you watch the playoff
games and you watch what the Patriots
did to Patrick my Holmes and kept him in
the pocket if you watch what the
Patriots did to Jared Goff and kept him
in the pocket if you watch what the
Patriots did to Phillip Rivers the way
they rushed him in the pocket you
realized that if you're gonna win a
championship you're gonna have to have
somebody who can throw the ball from the
pocket now if you're willing to say
that's not really as important then fine
I don't know what evidence you're gonna
use to support that but go ahead hmm you
mentioned Trey flowers and how you were
there to Scout him what a career he's
really blossomed into it the Patriots an
invaluable member what's interesting
though is in the words of the the
mistress of Henry ii of france back in
the 15th century to have a good enemy
choose a friend he always knows where to
strike there's a lot of friends of Bill
Belichick that are now sprinkled
throughout the league there's one in
Miami now there is in Detroit in Houston
and Tennessee is there gonna be a market
for tray that cable market portray that
because I see huge mingling first of all
versatility strikes you right away with
tray he can play inside or outside he
can play base end if you want him to he
could rush from the outside he can go
and play it inside he's one of the great
kids of all time money he's not gonna
change this kid he likes football and so
the contract isn't going to change how
he plays so you're not worried about is
he going to become spoiled by the deal
right you know will he fit into the
Patriots play a structure probably not
the Patriots don't pay you know they're
gonna move on and find somebody else
don't miss him tremendously that he'll
be hard for them to replace but they
probably won't pay for them and that's
just the way they are and they move on
but I could see the Lions would be
desperate to get them I could see the
dolphins being desperate to get them
hell I could see the Kohl
I mean there's every name in illegal
once a good defensive lineman's gonna
want Trey Trey flowers Detroit in Miami
are so interesting because it's really
the last 2 DC's the Patriots does it
then become which DC did he enjoy
playing for more or is it then get down
to brass tacks and dollars well I think
you know obviously with Florida having
no state income tax like this have a
huge advantage right away right I'm big
to hoe you know I think it'll come down
to how his comfort is with the defense
how he feels about certain things but
you know it's a lot of this is going to
come down to dollars and cents
alright the big whoa big offseason has
really be centered around the Pittsburgh
Steelers and I'm curious about their
there are two stars right now that are
likely gonna be maybe on other teams
first the guy that we know will be
another team levy on bail
what do you think the markets gonna be
for them and who do you think the
biggest suitor will be well based on the
Jets track record I got to think the
Jets are Justin's gonna try to go after
blue chip players because last year you
know they had such a disaster a soft
season in terms of what they did free
agency just looking at shermaine Johnson
yeah I've been horrible for them they've
already cut spent so long terrelle pryor
didn't make the team I mean Isaiah
Crowell is probably going to get cut
here soon so they spent a lot of money
last year so I think they're gonna try
to stay within they're gonna try take
the two iron out and hit it down the
middle of fairway and Le'Veon Bell gives
them that middle the fairway
I don't know I don't think the Colts
will be players for lay beyond on I
don't think he's going to have this
enormous market I could see the Eagles
being able to sneak in the back door
because the market may not be as great
partly because who wants to pay a
running back all this money when you can
draft Aaron Jones in the fifth round
right I know he's been hurt but he's
really a good player when you can draft
guys you know do you really want to go
ahead and spend all this all your
resources on a running back my answer
would be probably not especially one is
missed a season you know who's missed
time during his NFL career who's one
strike away from perhaps being suspended
again there's a lot of risk here and
then Antonio Brown you you've come out
recently and said you know he with the
way the amount he's talking what he's
putting out there right now and then
Kevin Kolbert comes out and says we've
gotten calls from three teams which
prompted everyone to go so there's 28
teams that are not
calling about a B how do you think this
all wraps up well I think you know when
I it's funny before Kevin came out
saying he had three teams I already
wrote for the athletic that he was going
to have to have make a statement that
there's a market for him because the way
that Le'Veon spy hate and the way that
Antonio's behave right it's been hard
it's been hard pressed and so in my
column I talked about it I I think
there's definitely going to be a market
but the issues are a couple of kumkum
couple things first of all he's got two
years left on the twenty six point four
million dollars remaining on this deal
that he wants to renegotiate so you're
going to give up a huge asset to then
have to enter into a renegotiation I
don't know how many teams really want to
do that right mmm and then you know the
guy has been unhappy you know the
Steelers which is remarkable considering
how unhappy people are with Mike Tomlin
they have 57 wins counting playoffs over
the last five seasons they're second to
the Patriots now the Patriots have 74
okay but their second best team in the
NFL in the last five years in total wins
counting playoffs so you know there's
something that went wrong this year I
think the Steelers front office their
ownership is trying to get it right and
that's why they're getting rid of brown
and if you take brown on you've got to
understand that there's a reason why
they're still is getting rid of them and
you can manage that reason that'll be a
challenge make sure you follow Michael
and Bharti M Lombardi NFL check out his
work on the athletic it's always great
stuff and then Mike before I let you go
national hand-sized day is Thursday what
are you measuring in it oh I've got
little hands I'll probably be a nine you
know but I put healthy rest left hands
got he love how big are those hands he
would ask you had to know everybody's
hand size but speaking of hand sighs
congratulations do you Adam for putting
a ring on your new wife's finger to make
her to get engaged or you know you
obviously had to know a little bit about
hand size yourself I did she was a six
yeah I learned all that stuff I
appreciate that Mike thank you dude
all right buddy hope I helped you know
you were awesome have a great day man
really appreciate it bye-bye
alright thanks again in Lombardy for
coming on he is the man he is somebody
that has always laughed at the media he
just really wants to honestly report
football and do the facts but I think
that there's something happening in our
media ecosystem right now that's a
little bit off and I don't think it can
survive this happened two weeks ago
during my epic break where I went and
saw oh those things where Jay Glazer put
out bold predictions that one of them
was that Odell could be traded this
offseason and then he got upset at
people because he was getting death
threats and send stuff which is insane I
mean if you're if you're sending that to
anyone the media
please don't it's so crazy and
unnecessary and disrespectful and really
scary to be honest but he put that out
as a bold prediction I mean bold
prediction is played to report four
years ago people like that's when we
would sit around and we kind of go all
right what's your bold prediction it's a
gimmick it's not real Colin Cowherd
comes out last week and he says that
he's got some sources that Russell
Wilson is trying to come to the Giants
that Ciara for her career and her
entertainment wants to be in New York
sent Seattle into an absolute cluster
set New York into a cluster - and I
watched both and I read both and I
realized we can't have this we can't do
this we have people in our media
ecosystem that have a role shefter and
Glaser every time they tweet it's a news
event I hate to tell these guys but I
can't have Jay Glazer tweeting out his
opinions like like and I know he would
get upset at me go why can't I I go
because Jay when you tweet out that
O'Dell could be traded you're gonna stop
the presses and you're taking over the
news cycle and yet I have Colin Cowherd
who only gives opinions and now he wants
to give you a source to fact these two
things cannot happen and I apologize to
both of them
I can't take Collin cowherds news as
news because of how often he tries to
play the edgy story game
I'm never gonna believe him it doesn't
make sense and Jay Glazer
I can't separate your opinion from your
fact you throw me through the you threw
me through the wash I have no idea what
to believe because the next time you
come in fact is it just a Jay Glazer
bold prediction I don't know and I know
that the hotel camp wasn't happy because
I saw all those tweets and just because
Odell was rumoured to be traded and I
know that's actually for a fact during
the season last year I don't know if
it's happening right now but in a
climate where you have Odell who we know
is gonna have all them clicks and we
know was gonna draw that tension and
every single person the NFL fan owner
team coach roster builder whatever
one I'm on their team it's gonna get a
lot of attention you can't do that you
got a stick to what you know with that
being said Bryce Harper is going to the
Phillies over 300 million dollars for
around a decade that's a left go lock to
left go lock just want you guys to know
just it's a left go lock and for the
real ones you really know what a left go
lock is for everybody else keep playing
the game keep not realized it's actually
going on cuz it's amazing so coming up
in the next few weeks there are some
scheduling things that you can already
get ready for combine is this week check
out Matt Miller and stick to football
they're gonna have a lot of updates he's
gonna be in Indy I think Connor is gonna
be going out there Friday and in two
weeks I'm gonna have those guys on the
podcast about the second week of March
and we're gonna do the the left go is
I'm gonna do left go inventory and we're
gonna cut through all the crap and we're
gonna figure out okay who's the best
player on this draft who's the guy that
you have to have where do you think Kyle
Armour is gonna go I'm gonna let them
get all this information now because in
two weeks is when we're really gonna
have an idea I want Matt and Connor to
talk to all their sources out there so
they can download us here on this show
and inform
Thursday is a national holiday I don't
know if you guys know this in his
national hand size day it is my favorite
time in the world what I'd like to do is
on Thursday I'd love all the homies to
pull your 33% and we're gonna bring out
the rulers and we're gonna do hand
measurements and if you have small hands
please don't be ashamed if you have big
hands this is your time to shine we want
to join in the fray let's get those hand
measurables out there and let's see how
we stack up to Kyler Murray the hand
that everyone's going to be watching
also hope you guys are ready it's almost
time for inappropriate question time
that's right it's that great time every
year where some [ __ ] on an NFL team
asks a super wildly inappropriate
question to an NFL player and then NFL
and then radio shows around the country
to mean a guy that we don't even know
who he is and say Adam boo-boo why would
he ask that question about that players
mom that's so inappropriate that's
coming up I'm gonna say that comes out
Wednesday Wednesday or Thursday who's my
guest for that inappropriate question oh
don't think you guys know this also come
up on the calendar anonymous scout
didn't like the way insert player was
during his 15 minute interview man
that's gonna be incredible hope you guys
are ready for that story because that
story's gonna be great left Gopi are
coming right at you hope you guys are
ready for the epic fail during a 40-yard
video where somebody falls this is the
Chris Jones oh crap it just popped out a
wart and if you don't know what I'm
talking about just typing Chris Jones 40
but there is always a time where
somebody is running and they fall really
hard and then NFL Network slo-moes it
and we watch it a million times and it's
kind of funny and then oh the
slow-motion offensive linemen run man
that's great and I still believe that
Andre Smith was one of the greatest of
all time and Andres Pete if you haven't
seen that you need to see it the only
other thing I'm gonna say before we wrap
up is for all the homies that are
watching the AAF and that keep asking me
if I'm watching it no I'm not I I got so
turned off by all of the NFL reporters
that were like this is this is good
football I'm really enjoying it I'm
really not you know I tried I'm not a
fan it's just not a good sign when Trent
Richardson is one of the best players in
your league and I'm watching a
quarterback battle between Mettenberger
and Hackenberg and then I'm hearing that
one of the funders of the entire league
could pull out at any moment if the AI F
continues to go and maybe it thrives a
little bit uninterested I could be down
but until then I need a little bit more
proof I'm here my man Matt Simms is is
not really doing too great so that might
be a real little reason why I'm a little
bit upset but I'm just going to say that
I'm not getting down I'm not getting
down at all to all the homies you guys
are awesome
hit me up fill out the forms and I'm
gonna send out now on Wednesday the
three possible new names for the show
and then on Wednesday we're gonna have
another gift for Thursday to break it
down get ready for the combine and keep
you guys informed to everyone that sent
me well wishes on my engagement y'all
are the [ __ ] to everyone that sent me
well wishes for the play-by-play rising
stars I appreciate you guys and to
everyone that continues to ride or die
with the lef koe
keep being cool keep hitting me up on
social whatever stories you want me to
talk about hit me up man you know I'm
gonna cover you guys are the [ __ ]